welcome back to the david pakman show my
name is jesse dolimore i'm sitting in
for david pakman while he's on vacation
thanks david i appreciate the
opportunity
to talk to your audience
hey you know how uh
donald trump ruined the red hat for
everybody except for magga turds
well
i mean
it's a funny story here
kevin mccarthy has now ruined the red
shirt and really taken the maga concept
the maga hat concept to a whole new
level
because if you've ever been at breakfast
if you live in an area with a lot of
maggot people
uh we'll keep it
respectable or we'll try
and you see across the parking lot
someone approaching and they have a red
hat and you keep watching to see if it's
gonna be a
a nike swoosh or if it's gonna be a maga
hat
and if you've if you've thought about
well i don't think i want to own a red
hat just in case someone thinks i'm that
guy
i'm with you i've been that too
but kevin mccarthy
in response to nancy pelosi calling him
a [ __ ] or reportedly calling him a
[ __ ]
is now selling t-shirts on his website
with [ __ ] on them and then in small
much smaller letters
the definition so if you're that guy
across the parking lot approaching the
the the storefront
all you see
is someone wearing a t-shirt proclaiming
themselves
to be a [ __ ]
i'm going to read from his website here
oppose the moronic mask mandate with
this exclusive t-shirt
nancy pelosi just called kevin mccarthy
a [ __ ] for opposing the mask
mandate by the way
verbally and parenthetically here
you are a [ __ ] gavin mccarthy
if you're opposing a mask mandate to
keep americans
safe and
healthy uh
back to the website
you're a top patriot and he needs you
to get this t-shirt to oppose her
and the radical left socialist and the
radical socialist left
yeah because nancy pelosi is a socialist
and then underneath here will you and
one friend order your limited edition
t-shirt today
really shilling for for multiple
t-shirts to be sold and then here which
is a little bit more pernicious and not
quite as uh hilarious
is this fundraising tactic that has been
uh normalized across the republican
party platforms for fundraising if
you've given up on house republicans and
our fight against the socialist left
uncheck this box but
if you still stand with us
leave this box checked and make your
monthly donation to bold patriots
fighting back against pelosi
and this socialist left and then small
print make this a monthly recurring
donation
that is trickery it is not clear what is
taking place they're manipulating
if you've given up on the house
republicans uncheck this box but if
you're still with us you patriot
then check it and give us money on a
reoccurring monthly basis
a lot of people who give to the
republican party as you can see
it's it's it's default for occupation is
retired there a lot of people are on a
fixed income
donald trump it was just reported had to
give back like 135 million dollars or
something wild like that i don't have
the figure in my head um
but had to had to refund money from
people they were bilking who were
unaware that there was going to be a a
continuing charge so
if you're interested out there you can
go get your [ __ ] shirt and walk around
proclaiming to everyone
just how moronic you are
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and daily energy i
have struggled with sleep at times in my
life i've tried many different things
and rise has been really useful
it tracks your sleep debt which is how
much sleep you essentially owe your body
tracks your general rhythms helps you
understand your daytime energy levels
and rise can improve your sleep and
energy by giving you personalized
feedback about your sleep metrics when
you should go to bed when you should
wake up in terms of optimizing your
personal rest it can even tell you
things like how long should you expect
to be groggy in the morning based on
when you wake up you can make
science-based improvements to 16
different habits that will make you feel
more rested every day and most rise
users start feeling that way in the
first five days including me and ryze is
still helping me every day it's great
it's based on real sleep science
very few things are as important as
improving your sleep go to rise
science.com
pacman to try rise free for a week the
link is underneath this video